hello you are watching uh the press
preview it's our first look at what is
on the front pages as they arrive and
tonight we'll be discussing the
headlines with former mp and broadcaster
anna soubry and daily mirror columnist
susie boniface they'll be with us until
just before midnight speaking to them in
a moment but first of all let's see what
is on some of those uh front pages
and we start with the daily mirror he
died serving the people
on to the financial times it says the
fatal stabbing of sir david amos has
reignited the politicians safety debate
here's your yorkshire post writing about
joe cox's sister kim ledbeter feeling
horrified uh joe cox of course was the
mp for batley and spen in yorkshire
before she was killed five years ago
well the express writes about a terror
probe into sadavid's murder
at the sun also leading on that story of
a terror probe also writing that sir
david amos was a campaigner on animal
welfare
at the times leads with the headline
tory mp stabbed to death it includes
tributes to sir david amos
and tonight we are joined by anna subri
and susie bonaface thank you both very
much indeed for joining us on what has
been the most
awful of days not only here in essex but
in westminster and indeed across the
country um anna perhaps we can start
with you
um you knew
sir david you both served
in the commons together tell me about
your memories of him
well i didn't know him
particularly well
but he was one of those great characters
um i think he was always a back venture
and he did that
willingly and through choice and he
served his constituents as you know
because you're there you've heard the
the huge and wonderful tributes that
have been paid to him but he had this um
really lovely he wanted south end as
your news reports have said he wanted
southend to become a city so at every
opportunity
whatever the subject he would always
somehow slip in the fact that south end
should be a city and then he might put
in the rest of the question what was
something that was actually relevant to
the topic that was being debated but he
did this beautifully and we always used
to give him a huge cheer for that so i
think he was a fabulous example of a
first-class
constituency mp and he was also he was
also a very nice man very decent man and
a very happy man
yeah we've heard a lot about uh uh that
famous sense of humor that he had uh the
mirror sums it up very well i think
susie doesn't it their headline very
simple uh he died serving the people and
that really was what he was all about
four decades almost of serving the good
people of this part of essex
yeah and if you're not a westminster
watcher or a south end resident
david amos and what he's achieved in
those 40-odd years is probably
you know something that hasn't crossed
your radar until tonight and we've a lot
of us have sadly learned more about him
since he's died but
there are an awful lot of people in the
houses of parliament mps and their staff
who like david
came from very poor
humble beginnings
who came through
state
comprehensive and grammar school system
who
hold themselves up by their bootstraps
and really have a sense of duty and
public service and there's a lot of that
in all the parties on the back benches
and there are many um well it's used
about the tory party as grandes i
suppose but
the same applies to labour and the
liberal democrats and the other parties
the snp and and the us unions and so on
who are kind of the old war horses of of
the political system of public life who
are there because they have a sense of
duty
and uh i was listening to an interview
with david that he gave a little while
ago to ian dale
earlier on and he said one of the things
that really he really got his goat was
when a politician
someone woke up one day and decided they
were going to you know gift the tory
party the the the wonderful gift of
their presence within it and they were
going to come along and say and he
didn't have much time for people who
hadn't come up through the party system
who hadn't worked in local politics he
wouldn't care who thought that they
would you know they'd just go into
national power and that would be it he
didn't have much time for those people
the area beasts
um but he's everyone you know i think
when something like this happens you can
really judge people by um the tributes
that are paid to them because you can
tell if it's just someone saying
something nice because someone's died
and they're not
david has brought out tributes from
people on all sides which are honest and
genuine and very very heartfelt and he
seems to have been a decent and kind and
very um
how can i put it very driven
constituency and peers anderson and lots
of others have but someone who for 40
years was chugging away quietly
sometimes not so quietly as well you
could be quite vocal but um doing very
important work how many mps how many
male white male tory backbench mps do we
see taking on endometriosis as a
campaign not very many
it was unusual
and at the same time also one of those
people that
you do get a lot of in parliament
someone who he cares enough about some
some niche things like that a
constituent comes along complains to him
about something goes right i'm going to
take this on off they go
and parliament needs more of that and
we're one down now tonight
yeah well said we spoke to uh a priest
today also a head teacher and both made
the point that if they had an issue they
needed uh taking up in westminster they
could ring him uh and they knew that he
would he would uh make good on that um
let's have a look at the front of the ft
uh anna fatal stabbing of tory mp amis
reignites politicians safety debate and
i know during your time as an mp you
suffered horrific
uh abuse and at times i'm sure we're
concerned about your safety um
when you heard this news at lunch time
today um
what went through your mind
uh it it it will have shocked everybody
uh and rightly so and it would bring
into sharp focus
the lives that mps
the majority of them live which is that
you know you want to be out and about
you want to be meeting your constituents
you don't
not want to meet them and i mean i used
to do and i'm not alone in this and
actually david who we are right to pay
tribute to but
he's not unique the work that he did the
way he operated as a member of
parliament is not unique there's lots of
mps doing exactly that and if you like
nationally you don't hear about it but
locally people know how hard their mp
will work and have that access to them
but i mean i think for example um i used
to do a bit like david seemed to have
been doing a sort of a drop-in type
surgery and i used to do this thing
called meet the team and i'd have my
counselors there whatever their
political parties were and we'd we'd
advertise it um dropping leaflets
through people's letterboxes saying look
we're doing this thing on a particular
saturday come along everybody welcome
whatever your problem is talk to us and
we'll see if we can sort it out blah
blah blah and you can bet your life that
after joe cox was murdered um that
stopped i think i stopped that pretty
much i know i certainly stopped it
because it was just
it was
it was it would have been reckless to
have continued to do it and i don't want
to put my situation into david's i mean
my what happened to me and others but it
was at a particular time and i'm very
happy to talk about mp safety but i
think that was a particularly dreadful
time in british politics and it all got
covered with brexit and so we didn't
actually debate some of the things that
we should have been debating which was
about the safety
of nps and which was also about
the the fact that it just seemed to be
completely acceptable to
issue death threats to members of
parliament to slag us all off the
caller's names and if you like that the
whole tone of quality of debate
absolutely went through the flooring
right through into the gutter in our
country and i'd like i'm going to want
to believe that that's begun to change
but that doesn't mean to say that there
isn't a real and genuine concern
amongst mps and particularly their
families about the safety
of that member of parliament
yeah and our uh our thoughts of course
tonight with uh sir david's wife and his
uh five children some of what you were
saying actually reflected in uh in the
yorkshire post uh their front page mps
killing is a attack on democracy they've
spoken like we have
to joe cox's sister
and susie when it comes to democracy
when it comes to the importance of this
cornerstone of democracy if you like
this chance for people to meet their mp
face to face
how do we keep that um
but also maintain the safety of mps it's
very difficult
well one of the things that kim
ledbetter mentions in there is that her
partner came home today and heard the
news and said i don't want you to
to be doing this i don't want you to be
doing this job anymore and i'm sure that
there are
um mp's partners and spouses and
children and parents up and down the
country who have had the same
conversation with their mp family member
tonight
as they would have done in 2016 when joe
died and
um one thing i'd i'd take some exception
to and i think that anna said was that
she was talking about what happened to
her in the past tense and i appreciate
anna's situation has kind of ended a bit
in terms of what happened to her but
i'm sure when she comes on programs like
this anna will still be getting social
media threats and unpleasantness
i get it sometimes when i come on some
extent depending on what i say
um and we live unfortunately we seem to
live in a time when
the the normal debate about whether we
do things this way or that way whether
it's right or wrong has stopped being
logical and about decency immorality and
it started being emotional and it's
tribal and it's do i do this because
it's with my gut and it's not with my
head and so the debates that we have
they've gone there's no longer any
debate there's just shouting on all
sides
and it becomes very emotional it becomes
very visceral and then it becomes
violent and then you get people like
anna had people following her down the
road you get people i've had death
threats in the last fortnight from
people because i wrote about
anti-vaxxers
um you know it's it's by no means
anywhere near the same as what's
happened to david today of course but we
seem to live in a in a situation and i
know sky presenters get this as well
where people do feel it is all right
threaten to send absolute abuse women
get a different kind of abuse to the men
but men still get it too
um and part of that problem i think is
because
of the algorithms that run our lives now
you know it's not just on twitter and
facebook but on netflix as well if you
watch one film one night they want you
to watch the same kind of film the next
night the next night the next night they
keep suggesting things to you you've
already liked once and if that happens
with news when it happens with politics
what happens with your films then before
you know it you're down a rabbit hole
where everything is exactly the same and
we need to change
that algorithm on social media just that
one little tweak i think would improve
things
and it does seem um
doesn't it
sorry to interrupt susie we're just
coming up to the break but anna i just
wanted to make the point that it does
seem doesn't it that um
so david almost wasn't part of this sort
of toxic nature of westminster he
managed to to rise above that and and as
a result he kept being voted back in
yes i i don't look i don't think there's
that in the chamber of the house of
commons certainly in my time towards the
end things got
very uh are quite unpleasant in there
but i do think following on from what
susie says something there is something
that needs to be said
paula sheriff who used to be the mp
for the neighboring seat joe cox's made
an intervention on our prime minister
during a very heated debate and it was
about brexit
but she begged him
to use language responsibly because she
pointed behind her to the the shield
that bears joe cox's name in in memory
of joe and said
language is so important because you
have to understand that real members of
parliament are getting real death
threats because of the
language which we are using and this
atmosphere of toxicity uh and abuse and
it was dismissed by our prime minister
as being humbug
and he got away with that
and nobody must now get away with that
especially not the leaders in our
country we have got to change
reset the dial on the way that we
conduct ourselves and our politics that
language that we use is critical and we
call it out when it steps over that very
clear mark into an unacceptable level of
abuse
okay all right uh anna susie stay where
you are for the moment uh if you would
coming up after the break more of uh the
front pages including the terror probe
into sir david amos's murder that's on
the front of the sun taking a look at
that
and the rest of the day's headlines
[Music]
remember i was born eight years after
independence and india was still trying
to figure out who it was
and trying to figure out the role of
women in society so i think as a society
it was very conservative as it relates
to women as it related to women but in
my family the men in our family
basically said we want the women to
dream we want them to so do whatever
they want and my poor mother who was
bound by social norms but still wanted
her kids to soar had one foot on the
brake and one foot in the accelerator
the combination of my grandfather father
and my mother
were three feet on the brake i mean on
the accelerator and one foot on the
brake and that's why we were allowed to
do whatever we did
i think that almost all of corporate
america uh you know lack diversity
because there weren't enough diverse
people who'd come in
and risen in companies uh they went out
of their way to make me feel welcome
starting with the ceo and every
executive they were determined to make
sure that i had the support i had the
developmental opportunities and the
stretch assignments
to thrive in pepsico and i'm you know
very grateful to what they did because
you know when you're in such a senior
position in a large company and you're
so different
you know it's tough to assimilate but
they made it a point to make sure that
they gave me a helping hand well you
know uh two things that happened one is
when i looked at the big mega trends
that were going to impact the consumer
industry and food and beverage companies
in particular
i realized that there were multiple
steps we had to take to future-proof the
company and one was the trend towards
health and wellness it was very
important that we transformed the
company to meet the changing consumer
and to change uh to meet the changing
environmental requirements of businesses
but more importantly a more immediate
manifestation of that behavior was when
a young kid came to a birthday party and
she was dying to drink pepsi but she
said i've got to call and get permission
from my mother to have pepsi that hit me
because it said
not only is this trend something that's
happening over the next decade it's
actually begun to accelerate now
and for me to make sure that our company
stayed incredibly successful
i had to
future proof this company by
transforming our portfolio into offering
a range of products that were good for
you better for you and fun for you so
darren started the big transformation of
the portfolio
so
[Music]
a
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
hello again welcome back to part two of
the press preview anna and susie still
with me let's just have a quick look at
some of the other front pages the sun
mp
murder terror probe is their
headline also the guardian
tory mp stabbed to death
at constituency meeting
and the saturday times uh quite simply
saying uh uh tory mp stabbed um anna
this is um
very difficult day for uh the prime
minister as well of course we know that
he was in bristol with the cabinet they
were having an away day if you like they
were going to be talking uh about green
policy ahead of cop
26 uh the prime minister then intending
to head off to checkers for the weekend
and then suddenly in the most awful
fashions at lunchtime today having to
make a statement on something that no
prime minister ever wants to have to do
no absolutely
and um it would have touched the live
the hearts of every member of parliament
um and i noticed that
that pretty patel is having um urgent
discussions with uh the met other other
police parts of the police force to
discuss um the safety of members of
parliament and i would imagine that on
monday it obviously people will be
talking about this terrible tragedy
and david's death um
but then they will be talking about the
safety of members of parliament and and
i think most members of parliament will
want to continue to be able to meet
their constituents but how we resolve
this i simply don't know
yeah it's going to be difficult day on
monday isn't it when mps returned to the
house not only
mourning sir david amis but also james
brokenshire who sadly died from cancer a
short time ago and susie um just a final
thought
from you an investigation obviously
underway um where do we go from here do
you think
well the
suspect has been arrested has been
arrested under anti-terror legislation
that doesn't mean anything particular at
this stage
but one of the things it does do is that
it means that the police have 14 days to
question him rather than four days as
they would do if it was being treated as
a normal murder should we say
so there's going to be an extensive
investigation which will obviously go
into
the suspect's home any materials his
internet access so on and so forth which
will try to establish what happened in
the run-up to the events today they're
also looking at david ames's um
constituency appointments in the surgery
whether this man was booked in or
whether he just happened to be wasting
then how it all came about obviously
gonna be speaking to witnesses as well
there doesn't appear to have been any
slogan shout out or anything like that
at the time of the death so far as we
know at the moment so
that's that's a seed it's worth
remembering as well though that when joe
cox was murdered in 2016 the man
responsible for that was also
investigated in the initial stages by uh
local anti-terror police in west
yorkshire and that his case handled
under terrorism procedures susie i'm so
sorry i'm going to have to interrupt we
are out of time